we must juxtapose good ideas with bad
ideas and speaking of bad ideas here's
joe biden
since it took office families are
carrying less debt
their average savings are up a recent
survey from the federal reserve found
that more americans feel financially
comfortable than any time since the
survey began in 2013.
do i even have to add anything to that
like that is some gen saki level lying
yeah are you feeling more financially
comfortable everyone knows a recession
is about to hit mark my words guys make
a note of this one mark my words a
recession is coming everyone knows it
it's probably coming in late june early
july mid july something like that but in
effect it's here the the price of
everything is up i've told you many
times i got a whole bunch of workers in
my house right now windows screws two by
fours plywood you all know this the
price of cars the shortage when it comes
to baby formula all of the stuff go buy
chicken breast at the store is it more
expensive or less expensive is your
dollar going further or less far is gas
up or down like every single thing that
he just said there is a lie now again i
get it
joe biden is an old confused man
pretending to be president he's not in
charge and he's just reading what
someone puts in front of him and he has
no uh he's simply not in touch with
reality and he is a shell of the
whatever that guy was you know the guy
that's been in government for 47 years
but it's just a perfect example of how
everything that they say is a lie we've
shifted into this weird thing where the
the regime and the regime media the
democratic establishment and and their
media cohorts and virtually everyone in
the democrat party all they can do is
lie they they cannot do anything else
because they're so deep in the morass of
their own bs uh and it's not just that
they lie about everything they
exaggerate about everything they confuse
all of the issues and everything else
here's uh new york representative monder
jones saying the quiet part out loud
about a little something enough of your
thoughts and prayers enough
enough
you will not stop us from advancing the
protecting our kids act today
you will not stop us from passing it in
the house next week and you will not
stop us there
if the filibuster obstructs us
we will abolish it
if the supreme court objects we will
expand it and we will not rest until we
have taken weapons of war out of
circulation in our communities
okay so everyone that uh is in the
government
whether you're a congressman whether
you're a senator whether you're the
president etc you are sworn in to
protect the constitution of the united
states that's what you're sworn in to do
and if you do not do that you are in
dereliction of your duties and you
should be impeached or removed now i get
it that the machine doesn't really work
right it doesn't work right it doesn't
work like that but what that guy just
said
and this is just standard progressive
nonsense what is he doing he's very very
angry right he's very angry and he has
righteous indignation and i'm right
because i'm angry and i'm so angry that
obviously i'm right that's the the
double logic right that's the circular
logic that these guys use and they use
this with absolutely everything but you
will not stop us you people who do not
agree with us you will not stop us and
not only will you not stop us the
machine itself the structure of the
united states the laws that we all must
abide by to be here
the 250 year old documents that were set
up to free people and have done it in an
absolutely extraordinary way we will
destroy those things if possible we will
destroy the supreme court and the
separation of powers and the three
branches of government by packing the
court if necessary so it can do
legislatively what we cannot do right
now we will destroy every piece of the
thing if you do not do what we want i
don't know how you could be in more
dereliction of your duties to do that of
the oath of office that you swore i
assure you that donald trump never
threatened to break down a branch of
government but this is this is
mainstream stuff in the democrat party
there will be no democrat that will say
guys that's a bit of a bridge too far to
try to take out one of the branches of
government they're just gonna keep going
with it and keep going with it